messieurs dames nous allons aujourd'hui
lire quelques commentaires vous savez
cet endroit plein de bonnes choses de
sincérité et d'émotion
on va regarder quand on regarde la vidéo
squeeze a changé parce qu'on n'a plus de
44 mais il s'est vu des vidéos les plus
commentés de ma chaîne et je pense qu'il
ya des perles dans les commentaires ma
mère a regardé la vidéo elle était tout
le temps en train d'encaisser une fois
une petite bise à ta mère de ma part je
te soutiens dans sa démarche tu es
honnête avec nous et ça ne peut être
qu'à ton avantage
oui ssh youn est comblée donc je ne vais
plus quid échange parce qu'il a
maintenant de la barbe et oui et oui le
corps de l'âge peut être encore un peu
mais en tout cas la virilité elle arrive
j'aime bien quand tu rage mais sinon tu
étais mieux avant mais aujourd'hui tu là
encore plus continue j'ai pas tout
compris et manu tu fais vraiment des
trucs chelous avec tes mains xd n'ont
ils rien de bien que je n'apprécie pas
tout contenu généralement bas la suite
nous intéresse pas alors [ __ ] je peux
pas croire qu'il prenne la peine de
s'expliquer salle fragiles alors quand
on s'appelle charles ont fait pas trop
le malin j'aime frapper les femmes je ne
vois pas où est le problème
je pense que tu regarde la vidéo ça doit
être dur de garder sa modestie de ne pas
perdre la tête face à la ça doit être
dur de garder sa modestie de ne pas
perdre la tête face à plus tard a pas
perdre la tête face à l'as et brice et
pétards ça doit être dur de garder la
manière de ne pas avoir que la grosse
tête et de ne pas avoir changé donc je
suis plus que je voulais dire les
squeeze beaucoup de gens veulent un
autre costume taillé mais tu aurais
beaucoup de vue qu'on bat les couilles
des rues beach on ne doit plus de 2
milliards je suis désolé aujourd'hui je
prends avec le plaisir est arrogant
[ __ ] un gros pavé de yoshi benders bon
sans vouloir faire mon inter chose que
je ne fais généralement jamais je te
crois pas sur la fin par rapport à ta
politique des vidéos youtube je veux
dire que nous dit moi pas tu aimes pas
le fric quoi je t'aimais bien avant mais
[ __ ] tu pouvais pas rester sur youtube
où les de partir dans des registres
différents
c'est bien pourtant évolué et changé de
point de vue sur toi à nous lire la
suite
mais sérieux fais gaffe parce que tu
fais mais toi à la place des gens j'ai
pas trop compris si tu me reproches au
final aux alertes buts à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un message à travers ça
mais non quizy change parce qu'il a
maintenant de la barbe
si seulement vous pouviez la touche et
ça c'est des centaines de rasage en
espérant que ça pousse plus vite et plus
épais bravo pour ce que tu as dit [ __ ]
tu as de la barbe
arrêter maintenant c'est commercial et
plus marrant ça non
[ __ ] punch ou le berger a posté un
commentaire ce que tu fais est sans
intérêt rythme très très rapide tu
parles un mec imaginaire tu es un
comportement débile et toujours à des
espèces de jeu absurde inutile du tout
créatif et qui ne font pas avancer le
schmilblick
ok la [ __ ] 50 ans j'en ai ras la patate
de plus de 60 ans pardon de te voir dans
le fil d'actualité vous n'êtes
finalement qu'une poignée de france à
proposer du contenu divertissant mais
intéressant sur youtube malheureusement
tu n'en feras tu mens pas partie aérez
vous la tête un peu molle a alors pour
une folle berges et quel type de vidéos
regardes-tu alors au niveau de tes
vidéos mises en ligne ces trucs tiré de
la télé décryptage du pic pétrolier on
est loin des vidéos de squeeze c'est
clair façonnage à la main made in
australia
mais vraiment loin forcément tu vas rien
apprendre en voyant mes vidéos ça va
clairement pas d'intéresser regardons ce
que tu as fait ces derniers temps sur
youtube expérience sur le corbeau est
jeune et un petit bâton devant la boîte
one box c'est une chose d'utiliser un
outil pour attraper de la nourriture ce
qui a déclenché le processus
technologique us et lorsque l'un
d'accord top des sons les plus tristes
du monde en plus est dans une mauvaise
passe berger bon allez on pardonne parce
que tu as dire à la patate située à blé
du documentaire sur les corbeaux tu t'es
testera ma chaîne c'est clara et moi
j'aime bien les documentaires aussi un
et je déteste machette et un squeeze à
des enfants qui regardent des vidéos
s'amuser à des enfants qui regardent mes
idéaux je suis d'accord avec toi squeeze
car marion les plombiers je joue depuis
un an je suis toujours pas devenu
plombier tas de l'avenir gamin mdr mais
c'était drôle que trois minutes sur une
aire pour toi des questions à traiter
pas drôle tout court merde
oh [ __ ]
au plus tard d'accord donc déjà que tu
seras gentil de ne pas donner des ordres
à ses abonnés excuse moi c'est bon
ensuite les quetsches le thème c'est un
moyen de communiquer avec ses abonnés il
me semble que c'est important bayrou il
me semble que c'est plutôt important de
faire des vidéos que tu es à bonne école
de pensée athée abonnés avant de penser
à ton petit plaisir d'accord d'arrivée
ce pardon je vais je suis désolé m après
scheckter mais que les gens commençaient
de l'attrait pour une raison qui
m'échappe
c'est l'apparition de la barbe et la
vérité ouais tu fais des vidéos gaming
ouais super innovateur ça mais toi tu
fais quoi darius je ne fais pas de
vidéos dont j'ai peut-être mal à croire
que j'ai deux abonnés m'enfin donc tu es
content bref je t'aime pas toi je
regrette et vieux temps en temps pour
voir ce que ça donne avant j'aimais
beaucoup ce que tu faisais alors c'est
peut-être moi qui ai changé mais depuis
quelques mois je retrouve plus côté cool
dû avancer que de 1,20 visite à changer
les vidéos étaient plus marrante est
devenu un couvent et bien sûr je lâche
le petit pouce rouge pour l'ordre qui a
été très mal venu cet homme a
l'impression qu'on lui donne des ordres
alors que pas du tout bon il ya donc
bien eu suis un psychopathe voilà je
n'oserais jamais te demander le sel
parce que tu vas quarks et un ordre tu
vas me mettre une droite enfin [ __ ]
enfin tu dis au gamin d'aller sur [ __ ]
et ça passe c'est pas exactement ça
salut g8 a réglé je trouve que le
contenu avec les gros mots s'écoule un
like ta gueule et se met à reculer de
kikoo attend lui tue les enfants dans la
rue c'est sur le wiki la haine contre
les enfants mais j'ai une amie qui est
un cousin le jour je suis allée chez
elle et son cousin un bon trip de tes
vidéos frère de mon avis qu'il ya un an
que tu passes à côté d'une femme
enceinte entendra la voix de youtube aux
intérieurs le ventre
cette variété pour y revoir ça a changé
cette vidéo ne sert à rien tu m'as déçue
je regarde des vidéos car depuis trois
mois c'est différent d'avant même mes
copains me disent que t'es vidéo c'est
n'importe quoi bon si tes copains te le
disent alors au moins aller on va
arrêter de trop les écouter c'était les
commentaires de cette vidéo alors bon
j'ai vraiment lieu ceux qui sont
négatifs à mort y avait vraiment
énormément de commentaires positifs et
je voulais vous remercier pour tous ces
gentils commentaire vous avez été hyper
millions bien sauvegarder cette vidéo ne
soit plus le cas n'hésitez pas aimer
comme d'habitude et puis ça me fera un
max d'argent vraiment je pense qu'à ça
un gros bisous à tous ceux dont on a lu
le commentaire vous est adorable
on va finir sur un commentaire positif
par exemple et squeeze tu peux faire une
vidéo sur league of legend ça serait
bien merci pour tout le soutien qu'il
leur faille à très bonne voie cette
vidéo par des mots bien john bis